[Music]
Chuck not much I had a bad episode last
time I let's start over what's up tell
me what really happened I wasn't just a
bad episode I died how many times three
against what the same thing like a butt
slug anyway the only good news out of
that is I did really well on the fourth
attempt and didn't take any damage so I
have a lot more health and then I found
a lot of gunpowder in this new area so I
have like look how much gunpowder a I
have one two three four five six seven
mmm-hmm eight five eight gunpowder a
it's a few bees I got a couple bees I
think I should be making I think I
should make a trip a and have more
handgun ammo wait don't you have handgun
ammo stored and I have 15 no no I
thought you put some in your safe box
last time that is you had like 65 would
you use that all Edam
what I used them on what though I don't
member that I used him up oh maybe he
was in that hallway with the liquid
nitrous or a man with eyes I don't you
know I don't remember it though I know
it they go quickly because it takes so
many damn bullets to kill a zombie
burned through them really fast anyway
now I have 76 so that's great
[Music]
something I didn't get that I'm upset
about is I didn't get any new saves so I
have three pucks left and that's not
enough but I don't like it do I need
anything else do you think I should
bring the lockpick or this crank maybe
the lockpick just in case just in case I
know yeah I have a grenade launcher I
have
yeah I feel pretty good I got I got some
mixer and then I got another green and
I'm on and I'm on fine so I feel you're
good I feel I feel pretty good
all right you ready mm-hmm you see
search this room pretty thoroughly yeah
I did in Lando last episode remember
what we were talking and there was
nothing in here I was really
disappointed about the like nothing I
think what upsets me the most is that
there wasn't enough save pucks I really
would like another safe puck I think I'd
feel better if I had one anyway I'll do
one more other than quick
I'll shoot I have like no visual and
Rick lung quest
how come it's red I think I think if I
leave the room there's something maybe
it's just I don't know who knows maybe
it's just counts the save boxes items
I'm saying like can I leave this door
yeah oh I see what you're saying
but that's the fire do I have to kill
all those arms
check the map again maybe there's
literally nowhere else to go
yeah I guess I'm going back unless
unless or something serum that somehow
you didn't get oh yeah okay I'm gonna
take a shotgun and then because those
guys were like kind of coming at me in
like droves of six maybe I could get
like a trip headshot that's sexist shots
I don't think people say oh I died down
a little bit it did die down a little
bit I'm going back to the handgun suckin
eat lead fire zombie flaming zits on the
ground yeah there's definitely stuff
look at that painting that's half on the
wall that's now not on the wall okay go
on
yeah can we get it because there's more
zombies in here sounded like it ki it
looks like half of one though wait T tax
hour nice you know why I was so exciting
for me I I'm amazed it took you that
long to piece it together check the rest
of this orifice I checked that zombies
orifice no don't say that
he's on fire wouldn't snowman on the
painting that feller a girl that's a
woman someone has made a mess inside
this drawer Bo's I'm down i I think oh
okay there's a lot of them so there's
probably other stuff in here maybe
[Music]
yeah I think I wasn't actually scared by
the way I was just adding tension it's
okay you can be afraid that's right
take that zombie balls um okay let's
kill some more zombies did you like how
I juked them in the tight space yeah
do you think I could get a double
headshot yeah but no one's anything else
in this room no no I don't think so I
don't know might not even be worth it I
don't think I have to come back here
alright let's get them see you later
jerks unless we revisit Veronica and
zero after we play seven people really
want me to play Veronica tough not it's
weird there's like a huge gut check like
early-ish in the game that if you don't
have enough supplies you have to kind of
like wipe and start the game over
I'm a kind of being hyperbolic but it's
stuff that you left me
well we both managed to survive maybe we
can start helping each other again yeah
it's been rough but we can rest now okay
sure no we're the only ones left there's
no rest for the wicked
here's a gift for you
[Music]
nice
there's more on the table maybe we can
help each other and then he just walks
away though I should probably go back to
the box then mm-hmm
should I just go over this room a little
bit actually I can't even pick anything
else up they read that Oh save ribbons
right there in the door Oh sick good I
must my 9 just my eyes to see me
thoth my eyes deceive me try wait what
is that from I dunno I think I made it
up try the that's probably gonna be
helpful for a puzzle looks like it looks
very important give your soul to the
goddess put your hands together to pray
before her okay so before her praying
hands before her I pretty sure that
before is more literal than the poem my
biggest thing give your soul to God has
put your hands together pray for okay
try that is it put the hands where her
hands are praying probably yeah or
something but anyway try the locked door
just to see if you can open it
potentially it might be the last one you
need the Clocktower key for I doubt it
right okay so to my left
god of time alright that's pretty
impressive she recognized a god of time
fetching under him she's smart she's
capable she wears shirts with no sleeves
okay so do you think I need to bring any
of these rounds is this like foreboding
or do you think he was just giving me
presents wondering the same thing I
would say for now because I'm holding a
lot of stuff here I'm thinking maybe I
should get rid of one of these the only
thing it's close quarters get rid of the
green herb I'd say okay I'm gonna we're
not no I I have to go get the ribbons
and come back one more time I
I respect your advice
don't be like that one oh thank god it's
like those jerks
the nerve well it's like oh I went the
wrong way
well that looks familiar that'd be
really fun if you triggered a
no-decision I would have been very upset
I listen went out I had a couple drinks
last night mm-hmm
my reaction time is clearly on point
pretty good but not as good I just
thought you should know
all right so pucks away bring the knife
actually kind of think about really yeah
no just kidding I just wound up going
cool he succeeded I'm not hungover but
I'm on the I'm hungover from being sick
I'm under I'm on that in the aftermath
of a sickness
it's kind of like it's kind of like a
hangover you didn't choose yeah that's a
clock no it's not gong of some sort or
like a golden record I should probably
be aware of my surroundings before I do
this
[Music]
tight that was lovely
now I don't take it with me here so that
just stays there I guess you combine it
with something or put something in it
come in blood-borne father gascoigne
phosphite there's other stuff in this
room I just saw something I didn't
emesis is totally gonna come after me oh
oh it's a dead umbrella mercenary we're
gonna saw rifle you Inc we get a week
any word mmm
never mind thrower you gonna mind
terminal the later games I don't know a
minor my throne for what's a mine
thrower shoots mines unfortunately
unfortunately it's not a minor only that
would be more satisfying umbrella
corporation in something strike
when it becomes too impossible to
accomplish evacuate will deploy a
helicopter when you are ready for
evacuation
ring the bell of the clock tower so I
need to ring the bell of the clock tower
word but wait you haven't like really
changed anything you just dropped in to
find Chris and Evans you just survived I
feel like my motivation is just to live
nice room nice something's probably
gonna happen in one of those two rooms
before you get to the save nice
oh is that enough in a fast jeez
I like I have a lot of items
well I have some options so witch
someone needs to do in that box
that sounds creepier this is not a tune
I said this guitar was out of tune
you've seen that Will Ferrell's get when
he's the devil Garth Brooks promises to
sell his soul that devil of for a hit
song and then Will Ferrell comes on with
the worst songs ever I won't sing them
but it's worth looking up thank you I
could I mean if you're gonna take 10
minutes to just click along this wall
which door should I go in my instinct
tells me to go into the smaller room but
what other thing pulls at you is your
butt want you to go through one yeah no
say my my nipples are telling me to go
into the big room ok it's just nipples
or instinct you pick with nip okay teen
nipples let's see how this fares may be
a good precedent for the rest of my
third
oh is this the front yard where what is
that thing
what is that is it a dead crow a live
Grove he's gonna attack you now don't
run
oh I forgot coming get me
No they came and got me
they came and got that and then walk
through here oh they heard me yeah you
heard you there's a lot of those [ __ ]
I'm on caution from Birds
thanks nipples I blame the Pope all
right so you should try again sure but
just walk I got it
look she's covering up her nipples
because she doesn't trust him anymore
that's true so am I not supposed to
upset that bird how cuz when I walk past
them I'm good questions it anywhere you
go right now it's gonna be you might
have to just do some dodge and if you
disturb them or yeah ooh wait okay okay
you shoot those things should I wish I
do um use the first day it's pray
nothing already yeah what oh you didn't
do that much don't use it yet just
sprint around Steve you gotta [ __ ] you
dude that door yeah go through that door
that's the saber whoa
should have paid attention the map I
should have okay all right I'm gonna
deck you with a lot of birds kill oh you
[ __ ] this is what damn it down here
was worth it
I guessed pick those up but you're gonna
get I'm gonna get mauled by a bunch of
always get a couple of them I'll get a
couple of them now I've noticed we've
gotten a lot more blues and that's weird
because it's probably those demos drain
demos things they can poison you they
just haven't yet those stronger looking
liquors I think they can poison you
you've just been surprisingly lucky
they're the ones that leap luck is
skills I'm inhaling lozenges oh you have
an extra one gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme
just to yield you have a cough I have I
have a sore throat I'm not gonna feed it
to you
I wouldn't worry about the blue orbs
outside you have a pot right here having
two or three uses right there's still
another green but I'm fine with leaving
it I got so much health
there's gonna be something in between
these two rooms in the same room seem it
would make it that easy Oh a demos did a
couple of them yeah I saw it
stealing - sorry they came up with me
from both ends
what do you recommend there's too many
people nice nice you probably caution
maybe no I did get poisoned should I go
in the other room yeah but what yeah
quickly though cuz I don't know what
your health is actually you're not at
danger yet your caution I think judging
her how she's holding yourself they just
call it poison and you don't know where
you're at I guess you have to judge by
your body language or the actual I can't
I think yeah no no you just use it oh
good that's what I'm saying don't worry
about get those ones out
alright so now Chuck I think you're just
in caution yeah the danger one is just
[ __ ] crazy you could just use a green
herb if you're not comfortable in the
next couple rooms or just we I don't
know what do you think I think I'll make
it was there there are no items in there
either
it looks like it's clear
meet I like this area reminds me of
Spencer mansion
usually something going on with the
mantles here you have the lighter on you
know this music is good we lit those
candles should I go through mm-hmm
come and get some getting my bearings
I could probably open that door right
okay your gut was right should've gone
you're good you know should we play it
yeah yeah yeah okay all right
weird it's you can't get back there no I
can't
interesting this is room red yes
tried to move it yeah I said maybe you
can
like this piano is quite prominent but I
like you can't get to the part with the
keys yeah without keys pianos are just
big black boxes yeah sure it's true
wonderful some do within music boxes
outside you push it from this side right
right
that makes a lot of sense
push it girl
the only place left to go is having the
savoury was up the stairs I might go to
the save room just to put some stuff in
a box how funny that be if it said ass
on the map but it was meant like snake
room I'll keep one green herb on use for
the to get back to I don't think I need
all these different guns keep the
lockpick maybe get rid of the yeah
mini chapel it's a key cool game over
clock T can you examine both those so
you know the difference sure because
maybe that's the god of time key one of
them is definitely a clock tower well
they both say clock tower key but can I
get up here there is an altar thanks
Jill remember in the first game it says
they're called like mansion keys no
matter what but then you have to examine
them to be spinning no this is my safe
space this is my safe space what's going
on wait was the first one say well
winder key I think it's gonna be a part
of a clock or something cuz see how it's
got the it's got that little windy piece
that people have on their watches mm-hmm
okay well some shits gonna go down what
do you think should I just eat this sure
get it on all right it's bothering me
that's probably why I'm not allowed to
chew gum chew gum really loudly go for
the head shots damn it I thought I could
Juke murder you're injured
come get some then I'm already on
caution that sucks
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
go away music I can't believe I got
injured again anything in those orifices
there's waiting for you where do they
come from like I can't go through here
so presumably there's something gonna
happen in the room directly above the
safe room right I haven't gone up the
stairs yet you might have to all right
what would you like me to do now because
I could go into crow alley and get
another green herb if you're confident
you're not gonna get hit by them
I'm confident okay I will never die we
have you on record saying that suck it
oh yeah you have a better Avenue to get
there now [ __ ] crows I could take a
blue - if unless you think it's not
worth as well take head crows sick debut
album title no it's like a band name the
debut of them for [ __ ] crows would
be catching crows how about how about
counting crows because we count them a
lot that's that's an organic game that's
original Counting Crows hit single mr.
Jones
there's nothing about mr. Jones in this
game that doesn't make sense
that's the name of the Counting Crows
song
in fact when you edit this I hope you
play that song over it and know you hate
me for saying that because now you feel
like you need to don't you when you
wouldn't have had to before it's true
I'm not people will be so disappointed
if you don't though I have saved so much
time learning how to not edit these yeah
these used to be like not dying just
feel like you're angry you know because
I tricked you into saying it easy answer
Mike does that allow egos around the
office he goes what's that boy band from
Liverpool you know in the seventies
people answer him with all sincerity and
then he'll just stare at them with his
dumb eyes no I laugh you stare at them
with your dumb I hope something horrible
happens upstairs in a clock tower okay
it's a tower there's gonna be more than
two floors who I should have gotten more
bullets I actually don't have a lot of
bullets I got twenty shotgun shells and
I got seven handgun rounds do you think
I have enough yeah what is your nipple
say go upstairs okay
[Music]
I feel like it should be puzzle time
anyway oh damn you I can't go through
there stupid long as table yeah you look
so intelligent there oh no I heard the
nemesis
all right you just dodged that well
don't come run right through the there's
like six of them sprint keep going
run done Bruno what what's that on the
wall those red things I have no idea
cuz you try to use me one of those
before outside that substation that's
right
think it could be decorative but it's
really misleading you know what suck
stars if the only safe room is in the
tower on the first floor so you have to
like know what you're bringing up the
whole way that'd be really cool
it would suck it's like a puzzle no I
don't know this spotlight [ __ ] well I
don't trust it yeah red herbs how much
room do I have I room for herbs gonna
take them sure
I think one and then if I don't get two
items well I think this is a dead end
without pressing that button right I
just didn't I might wait wait wait
there's something else you press to the
right there just lock that what's what's
that thing was a stupid key but the gear
key which key do you still have mine you
have that one of their regular yeah well
that switch to this one it turned on
spot lights for like a second
why is are you gonna be fighting
something that's afraid of light maybe
sound like that door locked or something
I wish I had a better understanding I'm
just gonna do it one more time I just
want to see if anything changes so it's
on that door can you manipulate the
spotlight itself okay so
oh nevermind yeah was the third once I
just the door you probably forget it
pointed at the clock no press the switch
really yeah yeah I mean he's not gone
for good
well it was good he's dead forever okay
dingdong the dick is dead
no he's not what was the other option
he's the cord
what's the cord just electrocute him or
strangle him I don't know I would have
loved to see her jump on his back and
try to choke him in the head just throw
you off all right you look pretty high
up for going up a really small set of
stairs like look at it it's just sky
around you it's always a helicopter no
to was it alright you stayed
I meant to look for the save I'm in a
save room up here maybe the keys up here
right there they got something you'd sir
into that is there a safe box cuz I
could really use one there are so many
ah to ease my pain brother actually I'll
combine these um should we save kind of
tempted to save what time we even start
this episode maybe like a half hour ago
I keep going
yeah I don't save it it's just like
after our last episode I'm afraid that
I'll spend the time redoing the things
that I've done that's all we could save
in like 15 minutes
okay famous last words
yeah they are sorry look so you need a
gear do you think I need anything else
should I bring
I will replenish these check those gears
when you get the chance to probably I
mean I think you just need a gear it's
like you didn't resin you'll - you got
there's also something shiny on the bush
oh no that's not that wasn't I wasn't
what I meant to do I meant to get rid of
these I'm not sure what happened I don't
wanna talk about it okay so definitely
need a gear there can't press that valve
something shiny right here oh yeah just
some [ __ ] is that really that's it's
right there this is all too easy right
now are you sure that's not the thing
you insert in the key we could try I
mean it makes sense that it would be in
there what a weird nice game right now
the most stressful thing is that I
haven't saved in a really long time and
I don't want to redo it so it just only
encourages me more to say what I would
encourage you to start doing now is to
save your ammo for grenade and Magnum I
don't know yeah I'm pretty good with
some of the conventional weapon ammo
okay they both said beautiful in the
description so it's probably for
it's broken
I'm sure checkup yeah this way
that's the box to the right of the
stairs made yourself
what um I don't feel like I have enough
information switch up or down so wait
this that great things not where the
other ones they also have letters on
them a b c d e f is this the thing that
postcard said per put your hands
together no I don't think so
where am I missing information check
that postcard again just out of
curiosity so it's a goddess like on the
twisting thing put your hands together
to pray before her that seems more clock
oriented yeah this is like looks like a
clock put your hands together to pray
for her wait one more time look at that
picture mm-hmm up down up baby is that
what that looks like
but I could just be completely consuming
these two and I should well it's just
like there's three but on this there's
six oh wait I didn't mean to do that
but that doesn't mean there's gonna be
six options that just means maybe you
get three five tries just try up down up
is this a music puzzle where I'm just
supposed to listen to the other one just
try out okay and up again we're changing
the tune I wonder if you're trying to
make it like that one on the left you
might have to go back downstairs to
listen to it so doing them down always
makes it sound like the good one
[Music]
No
so on that one you want it up because it
sounds better up yeah but I think you're
trying to match it up with that box
downstairs that sounded we why not the
one on the right
[Music]
nice I was weird but I wonder if it does
anything if you play that other music
boxes tune we could try that Chronos
chain Kronos is the god of time so
that's that maybe you're supposed to
combine it with a key or no that's I
think that's a key honest I member the
first room after the fire yeah you need
the god of time yes check it now though
like can you use the dialer that's just
like part of the artwork to add Oregon
time okay so probably go downstairs it's
just weird that there's two music boxes
Jimmy you do it again try to make it
sound like the shitty ones think
anything happens ah this is no longer
functional oh nevermind okay cool I
think I should save right now up here
you don't have think there's a box
nevermind call that an episode it's just
I accomplished at the a decent amount
but I don't want to do again that's how
I feel okay we're gonna play right after
you don't have to say at the end of
episode no or we could you could say it
make it a shorter one then just continue
yeah um should I keep this gear you
think no if you're going downstairs
there's a save box in the room you going
to or next to it stop it
yeah I was gonna try cuz I fix that
thing I don't think they're related but
I figured I'd give it a whirl
yeah yeah you one of those has to change
direction I got a handle like it doesn't
give me any options yeah probably like B
did you try going up these steps are
here and pressing on the signer that big
they won't let me go up the steps I'll
try again
alright it wasn't completely fruitless
alright yeah we solved a weird minor
puzzle and yeah oh [ __ ] no nice this is
the best this is worrying me though it
shouldn't be going this well yes okay
yeah I didn't mean that is a slight eat
well yeah I did you know what I did all
along the clock tower alright if you're
doing all along the watchtower that's
not even a tune of it like that song
that I love so much alright cool so you
and me alright I'm ending I'm ending the
episode we're best friends till the end
not you and me
[Music]